he's a lustful weak individual
let me tell you something tony let me
tell you something let me just let's
let's play again forget this academic
with this guy let's just be honest come
here let me slap you
come here let me slap you yeah come to
london and let me slap your face come
here let me slap you imagine imagine
this is his face
this is a message saying this app has
been such a game changer to me i've
never been so consistent with my quran
reading before i knew about quran li and
you can get quran li absolutely free no
credit card for seven day free trial
what are you waiting for download it now
bronze sisters and build a habit with
the qurani app right now you can find
the link for ios and android in the link
description below
i think after a long time
together
it's true yeah anyways well it's funny
so guys we've got this video i can't you
know people send me this video i find it
very interesting yeah same with this guy
he looks like tony montana
one of the smurfs
i'm gonna die okay let's get straight
into it so in this video this guy's a
christian and he's saying some um
some things about the prophet peace be
upon him yeah i'm just again an
uneducated
i have no idea bro he's i don't know
what his name is but let's just watch it
yeah so basically let's see his points
take it dissected by one by one so
i said before that
in studying the bible specifically the
actions and the words of jesus
i have found that jesus is the only
individual historically ever whether you
want to believe he's god or not
that is without flaw i cannot find one
thing wrong with what this person did or
said about the verse in the new
testament where the canaanite woman came
and he said i don't give away for
salvation he said the dog
forget that that's that's that's life
that's in the new testament yeah by the
way just as sorry just as uh no no we
don't believe that this jesus would ever
ever
you cannot be a muslim unless you
believe in jesus yes exactly so let's
just make that clear okay now that's
very interesting is that as christians i
mean when you say you can't have your
cake and eat it yeah you believe he's
good yeah same dog i'm happy with him
saying dog to a woman yeah in this
industry are you happy yeah misogynistic
you know why because if you look in the
old testament bro there's stuff in there
where you cannot compare it with the
quran anywhere near yeah bro it's
talking about killing smashing babies on
the rocks above it's talking about
killing men women children babies
donkeys bob it's crazy so let's carry on
so the only person i would ever look up
to is one that i believe is the greatest
and that is jesus christ muhammad is
full of flaws so many flaws all right
and muhammad says that god spoke to him
one day and started revealing all these
things to him it always is the case that
the things that he claims god told him
are always to his benefit for example
muhammad himself declared that muslim
men are allowed to have up to four wives
yet for him he says god said he could
have as many as he wants okay let's stop
that
can you give me some instances and the
prophet saw in his life that
things were legislated that was
against him
there's lots of things for example war
would probably be the number one thing
okay if it wasn't his benefit then he
would he would have excluded himself
from war yeah exactly he would have he
would have left everyone to go out and
fight on his behalf and he would have
stayed at home what happened at the bat
exactly right he nearly died they
thought he was dead actually he was
fighting himself
he did absolutely the thing is that he
lived this is this is completely flawed
conception because the prophet muhammad
lived an impoverished life
so much so that you know his wives would
complain
the living standard i mean he they were
literally drinking water eating dates
and he rocks to his stomach yeah
this he in fact one time when a
beautiful hadith you know he he was
laying on the on the floor and there was
like a straw bed that he was laying on
came in one of the companions and he saw
him like that
and he was complaining that you know
there's the emperors and these kinds of
uh
other leaders in the world would have
this lavish treatment whereas look at
how he's living this shows the ignorance
of this uh this man and what he was
talking about polygamy in terms of the
prophet saws i'm having nine lives
yeah
it's not like you can have as many as
you want in fact the cap was put in
chapter 33.
so what i mean what does this prove it
it shows that the prophet muhammad
okay was put in more difficulty
these women were all either widows women
that had been in war women that were in
different political tribes and that the
prophet wanted to unify and so there was
a muslim there was an interest for the
people but it's difficult having two
three four wives and imagine having that
well if even if he wanted that the
quraysh offered him to stop preaching
his message of money theism exactly they
will give women if he was a person of
opportunity
he could have said you know what i want
woman yeah thank you my message was just
i made it up anyways he said if you give
the moon on my left or the son of my
right i will not stop my message so if
he wanted status money and wealth they
offered all of that he rejected the
mortar good point secondly
where um he frowned to the to the blind
man
so that was
against himself because it was he
rebuking himself oh the prophet why did
you why did you
frown at the blind man so there's even
there's quranic verses where it's
directly against for example when he was
asked to marry his um adopted son's uh
wife he didn't want to because it was
looked down upon well
clarified that it wasn't his adopted son
he clarified that this is
that was the first clarification yeah
but adopted it means it's not your no
but there is no there is no it was um
haram yeah
so adoption
it's not biological yeah yeah it's not
biological and he did and why did he do
that this guy touches up on the bible he
did that to
um stop that custom
is this someone who i'm going to worship
who i'm going to call a great leader a
great prophet no we we're not asking you
to worship muhammad
jesus
yes see you've got it all wrong you've
got the basics wrong exactly well the
basics for us is that we worship allah
the the one god the worthy of worship
that all the prophets came to tell the
people to worship abraham moses jesus
all of those prophets what's really
interesting if you look at psychology
yeah imagine the thief i'm known to
steal people's stuff
would i ever come to you and say bro
i've got this um rolex watch can you
look after it would i ever do that
mm-hmm you know why because i'm a thief
i think it was this is your projecting
that's the key here yeah because maybe
he's a womanizer he thinks everyone's
like him i'm being honest that's why he
thinks the profit oh why would he want
nine because the only reason you would
want nine women i don't think
it's for sexual reasons maybe that's uh
tony montana look that he's going for
muhammad also
was a war monger all right and he said
there was nothing wrong with taking the
spoils of war including the property uh
the treasures and the wives he said that
it was okay
for his army because they were away from
their wives to have sex with the wives
of those that they conquered it's not
true that you have sex with anyone's
wives the quran is very clear about not
being able to have sex with anyone's
wives when there was a system in the
pre-modern world which was not
muslim-specific
which were basically yeah which is the
prisoners of war women and uh children
would become
part of the war booty of the winning
side yeah that was not muslims
that's in the bible old testament which
jesus the god of the old testament
stipulated yeah because if you believe
that jesus is uh inseparable from the
trinity then he's the one commanding to
all the things that you mentioned no he
said it like for example the battle of
khandak when the treachery happened by
the
quran yeah it's people christians
criticize this if you look into the old
testament well this clear cut verse that
says when you go to a town and they
fight you and you fight them and you
kill the men take the woman and children
yeah the book of deuteronomy learn about
your bible please tony he did not allow
for anyone to speak against him anyone
who did speak against him he would have
killed a second luke chapter 19 verse 27
yes it's a parable but why did jesus
give this parable why this parable those
of my enemies that do not allow me to
reign against them bring them here and
slay them now christians come and say
it's a power for the end of times no
problem that's fine so in the end of
times he will come and those who did not
uh follow his way bring them here and
slay them now he might do that by
throwing them in the fire whatever the
point is this anybody that's against
them will kill them now you tell me
where the prophet peace be upon him said
oh anyone that doesn't listen to me um
i'll kill or execute them they're gonna
say that there you go hk so please tony
does that sound like somebody i should
worship well once again this shows you
once he's an idiot this guy this guy's
an idiot man because the quran is very
clear
and the bashar
al-muhailei say i am just a man like you
that revelation is sent upon me that's
not what
the quranic message is and just make a
disclaimer
we have a bit of an attitude with him
and we're joking and i'm doing on
purpose you know why because if you're a
genuine person you could have come and
done a video you know what guys i have
questions that i want to know because
there's a lot of people out there who
are not muslim they're like you know
what i've heard about this i would like
to know you're not coming with the
attitude
you'll say they're like a you know like
like a mug yeah
yeah yeah like you're done i believe
you're an insecure person that's trying
to make a youtube platform and maybe to
get woman i i believe you have the
attitude why'd you have to show your
shirt how do you know it's a woman right
where is this woman brother you don't
know if he's homosexual okay
one of the worst things
in my opinion is that muhammad
had multiple wives which i'm fine with
you want to have multiple wives fine but
now you're fine
you're teasing me
i knew it
i knew it you see islam is is for you
instead of having instead of having side
chicks mistresses and girlfriends that
you treat you you abuse maybe a
boyfriend yeah whatever yeah you know
boyfriends yeah so the thing is yeah you
have a woman you honor her you announce
the marriage you do nikah you speak to a
dad you give a maha look at this look at
the privileges islam gives not this
fraud dating the biggest fraud in this
planet dating a woman
i was reading a book on beauty story
there's a woman there who's talking she
goes i felt so ugly and i used to let
men sleep with me because that's how i
felt yeah this is the system that you've
had for women but one of which was a
child
she was a child
and this is the holy man no problem
[Laughter]
this is what you need to educate
yourself like well it's as good as
getting your you're throwing off your
legs
yeah take the little ones for yourself
yeah little ones untrained ones college
students they don't even the little ones
actually though
do you know who that is so think of it
this way jesus now the one that's
inseparable from the trinity
is commanding us or commanding uh moses
to take the little ones for himself or
his army right why why were they killed
so they can be raped but look at the
jerusalem talmud look how the jews
understood this for thousands of years
they understood it as you can take them
and have sex with them there's no
there's no uh there's no either period
that they had
there's nothing you you're taking them
you're using it for a little for it for
yourself what are you gonna do with them
so let me get this right according to a
standard if he's gonna reject the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
because of misconceptions
no no if the prophet cannot be a prophet
because of that because of your false
accusation by the way then you can say
bye to your god because your god of the
old testament has done
you can say bye-bye to the bible should
take the bible and throw it away i don't
believe she was a child that's not
exactly yeah and we've already spoken
about length you can you can write our
names on youtube and write eyes marriage
yeah yeah we've dealt with this video
many times i have more honor than
mohammed had he keeps referring to
himself in the first person as if he's
something look you're nothing let me
tell you something it's a little man
you're nothing you could not present
yourself in front of me conversationally
or physically that's that's the truth or
all the great alidah you could not come
present yourself the only time you can
present yourself to someone like me or
alidawah or the great z
zeeshan from smart agenda is is in in
the context of a classroom setting
or indeed if you just came and said
please belt me
you hand over the
let me tell you something tony let me
tell you something let me just let's
play again forget this academic with
this guy let's just be honest come here
let me slap you
come here let me slap you yeah come to
london and let me slap your face come
here let me slap you
that's all i'm gonna say come here let
me slap you
i think that's that that would have been
in fact i should slap you so hard and
then if you following your your god so
much you should give me the other cheek
but i don't think i think the [ __ ] that
i give you the first time you're not
gonna be able to give me the other cheek
in fact if you want to play the whole
other cheek game we should do it right
there's a graveyard we go to the
graveyard we dig a hole i slept once and
if you're still alive i'll stop again
guys i don't think i should carry on
there's nothing i don't know
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
come here let me slap you tomorrow let
me just finish it with once come here
but let me stop your face
off your face in front of your image
imagine this is his face
his face
you're there
until next time
send me more of these videos because
these guys absolute clouds here until
next time